[Alkış]
2000-2010 yılı ilk defa Akademik olarak
Mısır'a gittim Çok sevdiğim bir isim
Hatta hala kendisine akademik Annem
derim gördüğünüz gibi orijinal hali
böyle yani kıvırcık şimdi dokuz yıl
sonra düz saçlı olarak hayatıma devam
ederken Aslan başıma ilginç bir olay
geldi biraz öyle başlamak istiyorum işte
bundan 167 yıl kadar önce çok önemli
projede çalışıyoruz önemli kurumlar
destekliyor bazı çıkarılamaz denilen
konularla ilgili matematiksel model
çıkartıyoruz şimdi Her toplantı denk
geliyor her kırsal kıvırcık saçlı kadın
bir derdi vardır jöle kullanmak Genelde
bizim karakterimiz değil onların
karakteri vardır o sabah kalktığımızda
nasıl isterlerse o şekilde görünür asla
bizim iste
bu şekilde Durmazlar O yüzden ara ara
ben de tabii ki son çektiriyorum her
kıvırcık saçlı kadının yaptığı gibi
toplantılardan birinde çektirme memişim
unutmuşum Normal haline Yani bu halinde
toplantıya gittim resmi bir toplantıya
Hani öyle tuhaf da giymemişti da gayet
ceket pantolon toplantı sonunda ilgili
yetkililer tadros kurumun büyükleri
gittikten sonra toplantıyı yöneten Asıl
büyük isim biraz kalın dedi tabi dedim
Buyrun hem toplantı ile ilgili bir şey
konuşacağım zannediyorum bir daha
diskoya gelir gibi gelmeyin dedi Nasıl
yani dedim beni bisküvi gelir bu halde
gelmeyin Bu benim doğal halim Ben
anlamam dedim ondan sonraki genelde
bütün toplantılarda Eğer böyle denk
geldiysem benzer bir tepki gördüm
Sonrasında da artık yorum diyelim Peki
ben bu hikayeyi anlattım bu hikayeyi
Ben biraz sonra geçeceğim Ama öncesinde
bugüne dair bazı değişikliklere bazı
ilginçlikleri sizler için konuşmak
istiyorum Çünkü teknoloji dünyasında
insanın nasıl var oldu şu zamana kadar
yaptığı İyilikler ve kötülükler ile
anılırken ilk defa ödeşme zamanı Yani
ilk defa insanoğlunun yaptıklarının
insanoğluna dönme vakti elimizde bir
kavramlar yapay zeka ve yapay zeka ile
ilgili olarak birçok sıkıntılı nokta
olduğu düşünülebilir Daha doğrusu
Kafamızda bazı değişik düşünceler vardır
ne mesela işte Yapay zeka tehlikelidir
Yapay Zeka meslekleri yok edecek Dünyayı
ele geçirecek e sağlığı yok edecek gibi
şimdi bu tüm bu düşüncelere rağmen acaba
Yapay Zeka dünyasında sahip olduğumuz
önyargılara rağmen Peki dünyanın bu
bakışına rağmen Yapay Zeka var olsaydı
O insana nasıl bakardım şimdi birazcık
ileri alacağım birlikte Aslında olayı
değiştirerek görmeye çalışalım Yani
durumun nereden nereye geldiğini şöyle
bir inceleyelim karşınızda yedi tane
resim var soru şu şu yapay zeka nedir 2m
sormaz sınız şimdi Cem hocaya sorarsanız
diye tahmin ediyorum ben bunu genelde
çeşitli etkinliklerde sorduğumda Herkes
işte alt sıralardan malum birlerini
gösteriyor onu sormam diyorlar ya
şunları sormam diyorlar soruları niye
sorarız soruları sadece öğrenmek için
sormayız soruları taşımız da ki insanın
Neyi ne kadar bildiğine yanlış bildiğini
doğru bildiğini eksik bildiğini öğrenmek
için sorarız Dolayısıyla Buradaki
insanların hepsini yapay zeka nedir diye
sormak zorundayız eğer biz
bu için yapay zekayı geliştirdiğini
iddia ediyorsak toplumun her kesimine
her noktasına yapay zeka nedir sorusunu
sormak zorundayız Peki bu iki resim
nedir diye baktığımızda Aslında
beynimizde eski öğrenme lerimizi ilgili
ne çelişirse ne denk gelirse onunla
ilgili bu sorulara cevap veriyoruz Bu
iki resim Aslında insanlık tarihinin
utanç resimleri arasında yer alıyor
ruhumuza geçen Demirler ve
afro-amerikalı birinin söylemiş olduğu
sözler Çünkü insanlık tarihinin zararlı
insanlık tarihinin en yüz kızartıcı
örnekleri arasındaydı afrikalıları
yapılanlar lütfen sonuna öncesinde
söyledim Onlar bizim yapay zekaya karşı
önyargılarımız yeni bunun yaygın hep
beraber değerlendirelim ve gerçekten ne
nasıl olacağını görelim küçük bir oyun
oynarsak terminatörü her
ve önü aktör Arnold Schwarzenegger
oynadığını Sylvester Stallone'nin
oynamadığını söyleyecektir ya da yine
küçük bir soru sorarsak Superman'in
sevgilisini izleyeni başarılı gazeteci
kimin oynadığını herkese verdim
silecekler Nikos geç değil ama
elimizdeki bir pek uygulamalarıyla
herhangi bir videoyu herhangi bir
bilginizi dünyanın herhangi bir ucundaki
insana onunla henüz tanışmamış insana
yanlış öğrete biliyoruz Yapay Zeka
tehlikelidir bakın ne yaptık bu
görüşümüzü şu an yavaş yavaş onaylamaya
başladık Peki Yapay Zeka gerçekten
tehlikeli mi biraz da Bunu düşünelim
şimdi Yapay Zeka dünyası ile ilgili
olarak Öncelikle işimizi elimizden
alacak dedik neden doktordan daha
başarılı tespitleri var kanseri daha iyi
görüyor kırıkları daha iyi tespit ediyor
Alzheimer hastalığına daha başarılı
tespitlerde bulunuyor doc
bu İsyan edelim mi insanlık tarihinde Bu
ikisi ikisinin ortak noktası var hatlar
ve Kovboylar İkisi de mesleklerinin
elinden alışına isyan etmiştir Hatta biz
hatları tarih kitaplarından varken
İbrahim Müteferrika Matbaası Osmanlı'ya
geçirmeye çalıştığında hattatların
isyanıyla karşılaşmış ve bu sayede bilim
Osmanlı Devleti'ne geç gelmiştir
şeklinde okuruz ya da pazar günleri
buharlı trenlere saldıran Kovboylar
taşımacılık yük taşımacılığı yapan insan
hayatından sorumlu olan Kovboylar
mesleklerini kaybetmişlerdi bugün
insanlıkta Yapay Zeka sayesinde bildiği
çok iyi bildiği mesleklerin tanışmasıyla
karşı karşıya ve bu nedenle rahatsız
nedenle Yapay Zeka çalışmalarına karşı
bazı olumsuz düşünceleri var ama
hikayenin geldiği noktaya bakacak
olursak Tanzimat Döneminde bu be
ne yaptığı iş berberlikte adı berberlik
olan bu işin Aslında tek başına
berberlik olduğunu söyleyemeyiz Çünkü
kendisi Cildiye uzmanı ydı kendisi aynı
zamanda sünnetçi di aynı zamanda diş
hekimidir yeri geldiğinde doktordu
Dolayısıyla o zamanın normal olan bu
mescide yi parçalanarak asıl kaderine
asıl noktasına ulaştı Yapay Zeka
dünyasının da vadettiği şey budur pek
çok kavramı öğrenmek zorunda olduğumuz
peşinden koşmaya çalıştığımız özel
hayatımızı vakit ayıramadığı mız
Dünya'yı değiştirmek insana insanca
yaşayabilmek Men özelliğini katabilmek
gelelim müziğin adam bir kanun bir 1929
yüzlerin çok çok Öncesinde bir kanun
maddesi bu şöyle diyordum bir çocuğum
Özgür ya da köle olacağı annesinin
durumuyla
var yani annesi özgür bir insan olarak
dolmuşsa Özgür köle bir insan olarak
doğmuşsa köledir Şimdi şunu
diyebilirsiniz bunun üzerinden bir yüz
yıl geçti Nedenmiş hala bu konuyu
konuşuyoruz yaklaşık iki yıl önce Çin'de
bir Yapay Zeka uygulaması geliştirildi
vatandaşların ülkeleri için faydalı olup
olmadığını tespit eden bir Yapay Zeka
uygulaması Yapay Zeka uygulamasına göre
Anneler ve babalar Eğer düşük kredi
puanla sahipler s Kredi derken burada
banka kredisinden bahsetmiyorum devletin
size verdiği değer puanı düşükse
Çocuğunuz bir okula gidemeyecek
özellikleri ne olursa olsun anne ve
babasının hatalarından dolayı
cezalandırılan bir çocuk yani insanoğlu
çok da ilerlememiş köle yada özgürlüğü
annesine göre
en yeni bir dünyadan daha iyi bir eğitim
alıp alamayacağını anne ve babasına ve
göre belirlediğimiz bir dünyaya gelmişiz
bakın ne güzel hayvan resimleri Bunların
hepsi ile ilgili söylüyor ortak nokta
var dünyada binden az adet kaldı
en son 150 yılda dünya üzerindeki
canlıların yüzde 60'ını yok etti
türlerin ve İnsanoğlu dünya üzerindeki
canlıların sadece binde biri kadar
burada bir sorunumuz var küçük bir
sorumuz bizim Yapay Zeka mızın bir karar
çıktısı Türkçesi şöyle bölümü
mühendisliği ve ortalaması 3'ten büyükse
bu kişiyi iş görüşmesine çağır bu yapan
zekalı uygulamasının çok başarılı
uygulama olduğunu kabul ettiğimizde bu
Kralı da uygulamaya kalktığımızda şöyle
bir sıkıntı ile karşılaşacağız yazık ki
elimizdeki yapay zekaya paydar zekaya
payder zeka insanın topladığı veri
kümesinde öğrenen Yapay Zeka Dolayısıyla
ben bu kuralla sizlere iş görüşmesine
çağırırsam Mühendislik fakültelerinde
kaç tane kadın aday var Bu kaç kadın
adayın kaçının ortalaması içten büyük ve
kaçı gerçekten iş görüşmesi
da gelecek Lütfen bunu bir düşün burada
Tay örneği var var Microsoft un bir de
neydi Çünkü Microsoft bu çek bu
çıktığında insanlar şunu söyledi Hayla
konuşun Tay sizden öğrenecek tayın
ebeveynleri sizlersiniz dedi ve tayın
ilk mesajdaki Dünyası seviyorum insanlık
Harikasınız cümleleri Birkaç saat içinde
insanlığın yok oluşunu dileyen soykırımı
bahçe tipi insanları ayırmayı bilen bir
yapay zekaya dönüştürdü son cümlesi
Keşke bu afro-amerikalı ları
çocuklarıyla birlikte bir kampa
koyabilecek ve hepsinden topluca
kurtulabilir sektir Kaya bunu bizim
öğrettik Tayfun kendisi öğrenmedi 2014
yılında ama zombi uygulama geliştirdi mi
en iyi adayı işe en uygun adayı seçmek
için düşün
mm tane sivri var en iyi 5 adayı size
işte Saniyeler içinde veriyor bir yıl
sonra Ramazan Şunu fark etti sivillerde
kadın ifadesini gördüğü ya da kadın
Kulübü üyesi ifadesini gördüğü ya da
Hobileri kadın lan herkesi Yapay Zeka
ediyor düzeltmeye uğraştılar neden yapay
zekanın böyle bir enerjisi vardır Çünkü
Yapay Zeka bunu bizlerden öğrenmişti
Bizler Mühendislik fakültesine sistem
alanındaki eğitimlere kadınları ne kadar
yönetemiyor Sak yapay zekanın öğrenmesi
gereken veri kümesinde de ne yazık ki
kadınlar o kadar yer alamıyorlar ya da
hiç dikkat ettiniz mi Google Translate
ten çevirdiğinizde O bir doktor o bir
mühendis 2018 yılının sonuna kadar nasıl
çeviriyordu bize daktır biz engineer
bu olmaz Peki o bir verebilir ince bakın
doktorlukla yeşil kabul ediyorum Sonuçta
İnsanlık tarihi var olduğundan beri
insanlar hasta oluyor Bir de ya büyüyle
ya da bitkisel bir takım yöntemlerle son
dönemlerde kimyasal şeylerle insanlar
birleştiriyorlar Peki bir birkaç yıllık
tarihe sahip hangi sorunun sadece erkek
olduğunu öğrenmem gerekti siyah siyah
Türkiye ve son dönemde siyah olun yerine
aday yapay zekası yolu bunların hepsini
aratın Hepsi erkek kadın sayısının az
olması bugün burada bunun başlığı
altında bulunduğumuz için değil yapay
zekanın kümesinde az olduğu zaman
öğrenemeyeceğini için yok sayıca için
elimizdeki yapay dar zeka
Bu bir içmesinde olmayanı öğrenemeyen
bir Yapay Zeka Dolayısıyla bakın burada
olduğu gibi Google'da profesyonel
olmayan saç stillerini are attığınızda
sadece kadınlar çıkıyor ve kıvırcık
saçlı kadınlar da doğal halleriyle
çıkıyor Neden işe gitmek için uygun bir
saç stili değil de ondan Tıpkı benim
aldığım uyur gibi yavaş olun hem de ki
Yapay Zeka uygulamaları Yapay Zeka
uygulamaları kadını erkek olarak
tanıyabiliyor daha kötüsü ise yüzünüzü
tanımaması Hatta yargılama sürecinde
kullanılan Yapay Zeka beyaz adamla siyah
adamı kıyaslandığında Beyaz adamın ne
kadar çok sıkıntısı suçu olursa olsun
hiçbir zaman onu yüksek puan vermiyor
son bir örnekle toparlayacak olursak
doğal dil işleme çalışmalarında öğrenen
Yapay Zeka erkeğin Doktor olabileceğini
k
Bu en fazla ev hanımı olabileceğini
söyler yada daha ileri götürecek olursak
erkeğin programcı olurken kadının sadece
ev hanımı olabileceğini hemşire
olabileceğini söylermiş kadın erkek a
Bayramı daha üst noktaya gidecek olursak
erkek realist olduğunda kadının en fazla
temiz üst olabiliyor ve kadın hamile
olduğunda da erkeğinin fazla böbrek taşı
olabiliyor makinanın öğrenmesi bizim
öğrenme algılarımızı alakalı Heidi'nin
ayakları neden çıplak de insanlık verdik
aynurlar olarak adlandırılan bu topluluk
bu iş için suçu çok küçük çocukların
Köyü olarak çalıştırıldığı bir dünyaya
atıştı bulunmak için verdik aynurlar
atışta bulunmak için Heidi'nin ayakları
çıplak insanlığın tarihi o kadar ücreti
suçlarla dolu ki ve yapay zekanın Biz
yok etmesinden korkuyor
ve Mesleğimizi takip etmekten korkuyoruz
hatlarla ilgili olan olayların tamamının
değiştirin yerine sürücüsüz araçları
koyun yerine Türkiye'yi koyup senaryo
aynı ve bu senaryo içerisinde
insanoğlunun değişmeyen tek bir duruş
var Burada gördüğünüz sayılar
insanoğlunun uyguladığı soykırımın en
önemli sayıları ve en sondaki 603t son
dönemde Hocalı Katliamı ve Sevilen ise
katliamına Örnek olsun diye konuldu
şimdi diyebilirsiniz Yapay Zeka beni yok
etmesin ben bu katliamların hiç birinde
yer almadım 14000 çocuk Türkiye'de
Bunlar devlet korumasında bulunan annesi
ya da babası olmadığı için bakacak
durumda olmadığı için devlet korumasında
bulunan bir aile sıcaklığını özlem duyan
çocuklar
bu Eğer bugün bu çocuklar varsa eğer
Hayvanlar bile kendi sürülerinde Yalnız
kalan yavruya annesi ölen yavru ya sahip
çıkıyorlar sa en zeki canlı mı En
maneviyatı yüksek canlı 14000 çocuğun
bir aile sıcaklığından neden mahrum eder
ve tüm bu yaptıklarına rağmen neden
yapay zekanın kendisini yok edeceğinden
bu kadar korkar teşekkür ediyorum